[Music]
in teacher bully news
oh you Molly I'm gonna bully the teacher
I'm hoping this is a story about a
teacher that just walks up to a pin just
like what submitted by Bart Sox thanks
Bart sighs anyone have any socks right
now oh my god are they black I'm
supposed to be the black foot around
here that's your pirate name dude black
black educators have been fired after
mocking an autistic student in a hidden
audio recording
that's float sounds like justice got
served what's going on
wait hold on a second that was who
recorded it privately the mom the mom
porting device in the kids backpack
because the kids started becoming very
aggressive and started wetting the bed
so he has severe autism no he's 12 years
old huh and the parents were just like
like what's going on like why all of a
sudden he's lashing out like this what
the teachers just [ __ ] around you
know like for example like I know it's
unprofessional so you're not supposed to
do it when the patient's around but a
lot of doctors after work they might get
together I start clowning on patients or
whatever I make it just like inside tot
like talking shop and just like inside
jokes and like student is not get in I
don't know how they snuck in it but like
the teachers in the teachers lounge and
they're just venting having fun but it
was but it was in the kids book bag I
get what you're saying though I
definitely know what you're saying cause
like look if it was behind his back it's
not as bad as talking them in front of
his face but I think in this case they
were bullying him yeah I see but also
kudos and the parents were paying
attention to signs like that like
wetting the bed and like lashing out cuz
like something's going on that they're
not seeing yeah so I'm gonna play a
video I miss what in the bed
shut up don't know that that needs to be
explained real quick cuz I have to
understand why do you do this
it's all this [ __ ] that's always
revealed I used to it by now girl
Bart's like addresses like I with Geo I
can't I've always got my ass beat for
peeing on the bed oh yeah well you miss
it live let's hear about it oh you're
white what do you miss your time you
like waking up in a wet bed no I just
remember as a kid like when I wet the
bed I thought it was so funny but I
guess my mom would be so [ __ ] pissed
and I would I think so I had like a
little twin size bed me and my mom would
have to carry our mattress out into the
backyard in the middle of the night and
I just never seen a lot of sleep yes but
what you have to do this to me and I
think I was that was my only way of
getting her back for what she does to me
and I thought was so fun so you should
never beat her ass for waiting the bed
no wow I got to sleep in her bed what's
up with my bed that's why oh maybe
that's why mmm cuz dude I have to just
sleep in my [ __ ] wet has been until
the morning and then that was it oh yeah
mine in my parents cleaned it up but you
know finally I finally got a little bit
of love every time I wear you know
what's so weird about the [ __ ] behind
I have a where our bed ever you sure
about that
yeah my wet dreams yeah but I never wet
bed I didn't [ __ ] remember like what
it was like wetting my bed until you
mentioned that story and I don't think
that would have ever like caught that
synapse unless you [ __ ] said that
now I remember wetting my bed my parents
told me I could sleep on the other side
and they would kick my ass in the
morning well it's because I remember why
it's because they told me to stop
drinking so much [ __ ] water at night
I would kick you and what would happened
I've like will [ __ ] you I'm drinking
this juice [ __ ] I would drink that
juice and I'd piss myself and get my ass
beat David being like eight and he snuck
a little thing of Juicy Juice I like
under the comforter and then after his
pants gonna let up don't drink too much
water cuz you're gonna pee in the bed
and I'm like alright card slot wait you
can't tell me what to do I've to go in
the fridge like this it'll quit
no you Bears gonna make you keep the
plastic on your mattress no because I
remember I said that was Isaac I kept
the pattern of plastic on the map that's
the smart thing today that might be a
new thing do my [ __ ] you new thing
that I'm really happy about now is that
they have these like water protect what
is it like waterproof mattress
protectors yeah and that saves the
mattress you are missing out on a lot of
parenting oh that's like like yeah in
the pee off the bed that's important no
I'm okay old scary no instead of Pete
cleaning the pee off the bed I would be
cleaning the pee off the floor that's
right in front of the toilet in the
middle of the night I think I would take
him to the toilet and like totally be
right here you pee right here is it Pima
corner - sound technique I was also like
half asleep like trying to take him to
toilet coz he would wake up crying and I
never liked it took me a long time to
figure out why cuz it was like in the
middle of the night [ __ ] up so much
matches as a kid dude that [ __ ] look
like a [ __ ] dirty person's wife
beater now say magicite peed on like 20
times would be the same mattress my
uncle's will sleep on when they came and
visited oh my god aja I mean the sheets
are fine the sheets like a barrier my
bed smelled like piss yeah that's [ __ ]
I'll bet smells like [ __ ] piss no
matter how much you clean that [ __ ] salt
also mattresses are like the one thing
that you do not get used yep like a
Craigslist don't do that don't buy use
mattresses alright so I'm going to show
you guys is a video clip of teachers
talking no it's called hope Elementary
oh this yeah
the voices you hear the adults we're
camtonz
teacher and a teacher's aide
at one point we didn't cracks a joke
about Camden if he were to transfer out
of Hope Academy feistiest is a private
school like do they pay extra for like a
special attention and all that uh yeah
okay I gotta say this you you got to be
a dumb [ __ ] because the kids not deaf
or mute like what makes you think that
he can't relay that information if he's
severely autistic like I feel like
somehow the child's gonna relay the
information yeah I mean maybe he
couldn't and that's why the mom had to
put the recording obviously that the
teachers aren't fit to teach people with
special needs yeah because that's such a
this is such a specific type of
profession for you to go into to have
that type of personality yeah that's not
you know you got to be patient and
nurturing that's the perfect personality
yeah very patient I can't do that job
yeah that's the type of - try me - yeah
you gotta be either a patient and
nurturing or careless as a [ __ ]
yeah it might just be chilling and let
him do things yeah yeah
Carolus is like because you're not
affected either way oh yeah you could
tell that these teachers are frustrated
they're [ __ ] affect because like you
can't treat anyone like that if you
weren't frustrated yeah that's just like
that's so bitter
that's gross real gross what happened -
then [ __ ] no [ __ ] so you're fired
okay I agree yes so they are saying that
the school is looking into it and and so
they're so the school was just saying
like this was a private and this was a
recording of a private conversation
between two adults there were no other
persons are children present it does
contain regretful conversations note
they were saying it to the yeah
mama bill but that's at the school and
then so the principal was saying this
and then they also say like because the
parent posted that to social media so
saying that the parent never brought the
recording to attention to her before
posting it on social media so she is
just like you know like we could have
had a conversation before TV news that's
true like yeah yeah yeah and so they're
just doing that this has that Hope
Academy has built a strong reputation
for completely competently serving the
educational needs of the special needs
community these recordings are not an
indication of who we are we has to
community not to let the actions of two
persons reflect the reputation and the
mission of our school but that shows me
quality control though there's many
people that tells me like you you know
who's watching like who's making sure
that these classes are you know like I
don't know man it doesn't make any sense
it's just I do agree with the fact that
she should have brought it to the school
staff first before trying to blow it up
it's like what does that do for anybody
it doesn't do help anybody at all like
you should because they're tarnished the
reputation has tarnished now they don't
have a chance to eat to do better
yeah even if they like fix it get new
teachers yeah I know you know I don't
know I feel like it would have been a
good point for the school to immediately
discharge those teachers and be like
they don't reflect this probably would
have been better publicity for them to
adults talking yeah there's a couple of
different ways they could have gone
about and also the way the parent has
gone but me personally I would have
liked to have a word with those women
yeah I sure would have yeah that is the
same statement the principal is saying
that the persons involved in the
communications are either no longer with
the school or will no longer be with the
school after the semester so it seems
like they still don't have to say that
was an adult conversation like that
that's the fence that's like well that's
separate nah dude they should condemn
them and say well [ __ ] that we don't
want them you know we're sorry they
didn't hire PR team they had some
English teacher right that
like that they needed a better statement
a much better one no their attorney the
parents attorney is saying that she
intends to file complaints of the
Department of Education and it's a
[ __ ] douche that's pretty silly
because I think from a legal standpoint
I mean I mean they can correct me if I'm
wrong but once you release the tape like
that to the public you can no longer
admit that as evidence
really yeah that's why all in like
things like camera footage all that
stuff they don't release it to the
public until the trial is over yeah yeah
so it's like what are you gonna sue them
over because now you have no evidence
like yeah I don't know but I think the
teachers should go to a school in China
and like they have to immediately learn
Chinese and all this stuff and if they
can't then all the Chinese teachers are
just like whipping them and talking [ __ ]
and like you see this bean bow she don't
know how to speak the Chinese right
[ __ ] like the same treatment oh yeah
they gotta feel stupid they gotta try to
learn something that's impossible or
like really hard for them to learn which
is China yeah why don't you know the
physics Beach but like that's so it see
anybody that does something dumb like
that and then you get kicked out of your
job and that's the whole field that
you've studied for ten years you just
[ __ ] yourself
yeah dude how would she get another job
they're gonna think so what what did you
get fired for I was [ __ ] with this
autistic kid who knows but you're
applying to help kids with special needs
but you know what's so interesting
they're like people who are like quote
unquote behavioral therapists it's
really easy to get that [ __ ] job
because I know somebody who does that
and he's kind of a dumbass and legit I
thought grew up thinking he was autistic
and then I found out that he's helping
autistic kids I'm like what just I'm not
even joking I thought he was autistic
growing up but somehow he got a job as
now he calls himself a behavioral
therapist and I'm like II did the [ __ ]
how are you a behavioral therapist to
him yeah so you know the qualifications
are very kind of weak
[Music]